اليوم الخامس دخل قبل حوالي ساعتين من
الان خامس ايام او اليوم الخامس الخامس
بعد مرور او على هذه او عفوا اليوم الخامس
على هذه الكارثه طبعا نحن في هذا الموقع
مستمرون في التغطيه كنت في النشرات
السابقه تحدث قد تحدثت ان عمليات الانقاذ
ربما ستنتهي خلال ساعات لكن قبل قليل
استطعت الوصول والحديث مع احد المسؤولين
عن عمليات الانقاذ ورفع الركام هنا
اخبرني ان عمليات عمليات البحث عن جين او
حتى ازاله الانقاذ ربما تستمر حتى يوم
الاثنين بناء على المعطيات التي تظهر
تباعا خلال الساعات القادمه ربما
يكملون عمليه البحث حتى يوم الاثنين طاهر
يعني خلال منذ منتصف الليله الماضيه وحتى
هذه اللحظه
تمكنت فرق الانقاذ هنا من اخراج خمس خمس
جثث من تحت الانقاض
لاب وام وطفلين وسيده كبيره في العمر
يعتقد انها الجده
السلطات او فرق الانقاذ تعتقد انهم من
عائله واحده لانهم كانوا قريبين من بعضهم
عندما استطاعوا الوصول اليهم وبالتالي
اعداد الضحايا تزداد تباعا كان هنا في
اضنه او في بقيه الولايات المنكوبه
الولايات العشر المنكوبه في جنوب تركيا
طبعا الجيش التركي وكما ذكرنا سابقا فرقه
من الجيش التركي مساء امس الخميس اتت الى
هذا الموقع وشاركت لتشارك في عمليات البحث
والانقاذ وهي الان تشرف تماما على العمليه
بمساعده هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه
افاد قسم من المتطوعين الذين كانوا
موجودين في هذا الموقع تم نقلهم الى موقع
اخر للمشاركه او لتعزيز عمليات البحث في
تلك المواقع السلطات التركيه تكثر جهودها
سواء في اضنه او حتى في هاتاي في اضنه من
المتوقع ان تنتهي عمليات الانقاذ والبحث
تحت الركام او البحث عن ناجين حتى خلال
فتره قريبه طبعا فيها تاي الوضع اكثر
ماساويه من اضنه لذلك ما زالت او من
المتوقع ان تستمر عمليات البحث لفتره اطول
لاسيما ان حجم الدمار في تلك المناطق كبير
جدا طاهر وبالتالي عمليات البحث لن تتوقف
خلال فتره قريبه
مثل اضنه الى اي مدى تتمكن السلطات
التركيه دائما وفي كل الاحوال من اجراء
الاجراءات اللازمه بالتعرف على هويات
القتلى
باتمام ما يلزم
دفن الى ما هنالك والى اي مدى يتفاوت ذلك
بين المنطقه واخرى بالصعوبه
يعني في ولايه كاضنا فرق الانقاذ هنا
موجوده بشكل كافي والامكانيات الموجوده
هنا بشكل كافي وحجم الدمار اقل لذلك هذه
الاجراءات لا تستغرق وقت طويل لكن فيها
الوضع مختلف نوعا ما الوضع اصعب هناك لذلك
هناك الاجراءات تاخذ وقت اطول لانه هنا
قبل قليل يعني في حوالي الساعه الثانيه
عندما تم اخراج الجثث تم كان هناك سيارات
لدفن الموتى يعني تم اخذ الجثث مباشره
اللي بدا الاجراءات الرسميه ويبدو ان
الاهالي تعرفوا عليهم وتم اخذ جثث مباشره
لبدء الاجراءات الرسميه يعني الامور في
اضنه تجري بسرعه اكبر من بقيه الولايات او
الولايات المنكوبه